uh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ugh
uh
wow
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
so
uh
hmm
thank you
so
check
uh
so
well there we go it's pretty cozy
oh
well guys i'm all by my lonesome today
normally i have my three little boys
with me but they've got school and other
things going on today so it's
just me
but it lets me do things a little bit
more extreme a little bit more hardcore
than i normally would and
i decided that i was going to climb up
this little mountain here and build a
real proper snow cave survival shelter
and uh
i'm really happy with how this turned
out i was also kind of curious how much
faster i could get things done if i
didn't have to look after little boys at
the same time i was making survival
shelters and the answer is i could go
really fast i moved a lot of snow today
it took me about an hour and a half to
hike here and about five hours to build
this shelter so
yeah i was moving right along the snow
is about seven feet deep right here yeah
we had to move a lot of snow to get this
shelter made but using that saw to cut
the snow up in blocks really saved a lot
of time and it's just a lot easier on
the back and you can move a lot of snow
really quick
and that allows you to build stuff with
it too so you can get the walls really
nice and strong and vertical but i
really worked up an appetite i want to
get some dinner made
let's go melt some snow
oh
there's all my food
my stove
and my pot
oh the wind is really howling on this
mountain we're supposed to get 20 to 30
mile per hour winds tonight it's a good
thing we're sleeping under the snow
it's cold out here
i'll tell you what it's really nice to
have something to sit on rather than ice
and snow
oh your butt and legs get so cold
sitting on the ground
now that i've stopped working like a
madman i'm starting to cool down and get
really cold so i'm going to take the hot
water left over from dinner
i'll put that in my coat here
keep me warm for a little bit
piping hot japanese curry and rice oh
one of my favorite canned foods
oh it's so warm and delicious gotta eat
it quick before it freezes
oh my goodness i woof that down
all right time to do the dishes
well i tell you what i'm in the mood for
a little after dinner snack we're gonna
try to make some popcorn
[Music]
making popcorn over the fire so easy
just put a little oil in the bottom of
the pan throw in a test kernel as soon
as that test kernel pops then add the
rest of the corn and just listen to it
and once the popping slows down or if
you start to smell something burning
pull it off throw a little salt in there
you're golden
all right time to boil some more water
got a bottle of boiling water gonna
check for leaks lids on nice and tight
i'm gonna put it inside my sleeping bag
get it all warmed up for me
well guys i'm getting ready to go to bed
but before i do let me give you a few
tips about snow caves first off make
them big enough leave three or four
inches on either side of you so that you
don't end up snuggled up against the
wall of the cave that'll make you really
cold make it tall enough as well you
want to at least be able to sit up in it
it'll make it a lot less claustrophobic
it'll make it easier to get in and out
of it makes a huge difference you also
want to leave enough length so that you
have about 24 inches more tunnel than
you are tall
that way you don't have your head
sticking out and you don't have your
feet up against the ice you know safety
is also an important issue you don't
want your snow cave collapsing on you in
the middle of the night so choosing the
right type of snow makes a huge
difference you don't want light powdery
snow you want snow that's going to stick
together or that's frozen together has
lots of layers of ice in it and this is
what we got here today additionally you
want to have a lot of snow between the
surface and the roof of your snow cave
and you want that snow to be the best
type of snow going and stomping down the
snow before you start digging or
throwing the excavated snow on top of
your tunnel as you dig will really help
but remember snow caves are only a
temporary structure even the best snow
cave will collapse after three or four
days because that snow just naturally
starts to sag down but if you're doing
it just one night your biggest danger is
having people or animals step on the
roof of your cave and collapse it i've
seen this happen twice once with a moose
when i was a kid our boy scout troop had
dug a whole bunch of snow caves and a
moose wandered through our camp in the
middle of the night not realizing that
there was boys underneath the snow
and one of the kids woke up with a moose
hoof just going pull right past his head
and of course he screamed and that
freaked the moose out and the moose
started jumping around and then it
collapsed the roof of his snow cave now
luckily everyone was okay he didn't get
stepped on you know he just had a really
cold night though because his snow cave
collapsed and he didn't have a snow cave
anymore but uh
anyway that's kind of the big tips about
building snow caves and on that note i
think i need to get in mine
well guys it's getting late i'm going to
turn the camera off
i'm going to sit in bed and read a jack
london novel here for a little bit
i'm going to sleep i'll see you guys in
the morning
well good morning guys it's about 8 a.m
and i slept pretty well i'm all nice and
toasty in my bag
but i woke up a lot last night because
of the wind it was just roaring loud
shook the roof
just made a horrible noise but that's
why you make such a complicated entrance
to the snow cave if you just dig a hole
in a cave
the wind could get in really easy
so you gotta kind of make this little
s-shaped
entrance so the wind can't blow straight
into your snow cave
oh
but i really have to use the bathroom i
got to get up
i just don't want to
all right let's get up
oh looks like we got a bit of snow last
night that's why you hang up your coat
and your pants
that's why you cover up your boots
yeah we got quite a bit of snow
oh yeah
oh
it's nice and cozy down here
well it's kind of lame but i'm gonna
have instant granola for breakfast but
it's just me i don't feel like the need
to cook all fancy
well it's time to get packed up so i'm
gonna go put the fire out
ugh
[Applause]
so
uh
uh
[Music]
well it took an hour and a half to get
up the mountain in half an hour to get
down hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see more adventure
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning and check out our camping
adventure playlist with over 60 of our
best camping videos all in a list thanks
for watching and i'll see you next
saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]